[MUSIC PLAYING]
YIGIT BOYAR: Welcome.
Good afternoon, everybody.
I'm Yigit.
I'm the Technical Lead for
Architecture Components.
And I'm here joining with
Kirill, also part of the team.
So today, we are going to
talk about persistence.
Now, this is a loading screen.
This is one of my
favorite screens.
Said no one.
No one ever said, I
like to wait, especially
if there's some content
that they have already seen.
And if you are making the user
wait to see the same content,
it's horrible.
Like, you're a bad person.
I didn't mean it.
So now, how do we fix this?
We persist the data.
This is what we
recommend developers.
Whatever information you
fetch from your network--
different data services--
save it to disk
so that if your
application is restarted,
and there's no
network conditions,
you could show
something to the user.
You can make that
experience seamless.
And we say persist on Android.
We know this is a
very crowded field.
There's a lot of different
options, different companies.
And most of these solutions are
really, really good solutions.
Especially if you
come to Android
and if you're new to the
platform, what you will do.
You will check what is
inside the framework already.
So there's these
three things that
come with the standard library.
And if you read about
them, you realize
that if you want to put
structured data, then
you want to go with SQLite.
SQLite is something we have
been shipping since Android 1.
It's a proven technology.
Works very well.
So you go ahead and
say, I know SQL.
I want to use SQLite.
You go to this page.
This is the very
first page you see.
This is horrible.
This is like--
It's kind of trying
to say, you know what?
You actually don't
want to persist.
That's not what we meant.
But this is what we have.
So we said, you know what?
Let's look at this page.
We want to make
this better, right?
Let's look at this page.
It's trying to say,
I want to select
these columns, with this
constraint, with this order.
So if you look at this, this is
a very, very simple SQL query.
But it takes a lot
of stuff to write it.
You would need to define all
these constants, which are not
even visible on this page.
So we want to say, OK
that should leave us
some room for improvement.
And we came up with Room, which
is an object-mapping library
for SQLite.
We said, OK, let's step back.
We said, writing the
same thing with SQL
is a lot shorter, a lot nicer.
So let's go back to our roots,
which now there's an SQL query.
Then we assign it to a string.
It is standard SQLite.
Now, of course, if it is like
this, we cannot understand it.
We allow annotations.
So we put it inside
an annotation.
And if it is inside
the annotation,
now you want to get the
response from the query.
Want to say, well,
put it into a method
so we can understand what
the query wants to return.
Now we know that
this is a query.
It wants to fetch these
columns from this table
and with this constraint.
But if you look
at the constraint,
there's actually
a bind parameter.
This is SQLite standard
bind parameter syntax.
We didn't come up with this.
So where do we get
this bind parameters?
How do you get parameters
to your functions?
From the function arguments.
So we put it there,
the most obvious place
to get this argument from.
And now, last but
not least, we want
to know what it wants to return.
OK, so it is returning
list of feeds.
Now, of course, there's
that feed class.
It needs to be somewhere.
We have that class.
And I want to put this query
inside that Data Access
Object--
that's what DAO stands for--
because you don't want to
have your application making
database queries
along the code base.
You want to put these into
certain classes, which
we call data access objects.
So we said, now we need to tell
the Room that this is a DAO.
And I needed to
tell Room that feed
is some class that it will like
to persist into a database.
Last but not least, we need
the database to put these two
things together.
That needs to extends
the Room database class.
And so the FeedDao
we defined there,
we just say this
database has this DAO.
And the feed entity we defined,
we put inside database.
So you can have multiple
entities, multiple DAOs.
You can actually have
multiple database definitions
that access the same DAOs.
As long as whatever schema
you define in the database
works with the
DAOs and entities,
Room will figure it out.
Once you have all
that description,
you can get the implementation
of that database
through this builder.
It's very similar to how
we use Retrofit Dagger.
You define the interfaces, we
provide the implementation.
Now, of course, because we
are doing the implementation,
select queries
are very specific.
We really don't know
how you will select.
But there are other queries.
You would like to insert
something into the database.
So we say, OK, we can just
define Android annotation
to make it easier for you.
Inside these annotations,
these are actually
very, very flexible.
You can pass multiple arguments.
If you read this method,
it says, insert both.
You really want to insert
both of them to database,
and Room understands this.
You can send a list of items.
You can send variable
arguments, multiple parameters.
If it is readable,
Room will make it work.
You can even say like, when
you try to insert this thing,
if there's a unique key conflict
in the database, do this.
So it can also specify
these constraints.
So we have the
Insert annotation.
We have similarly, Delete,
or Update annotations just
for the very common tasks.
So we say we just
start up on the SQLite.
But there are some cases where
writing SQLite is harder.
For example, I have
this query where
I want to query these feeds.
But I'm trying to
return a list of feeds,
which means I want to
get multiple feed items.
So that means I want
to get them by ID,
so I probably want
to pass multiple IDs.
Now, in SQL, you will
do this in these IDs.
But you need to know
how many IDs you have
so you can put that
number of bind parameters.
But this is some
information we don't
know while writing this query.
Well, that's OK.
Room can understand it.
If whatever the perimeter
you are passing to a function
is a collection.
Room knows that, OK, they
want to have multiple bind
parameters.
At runtime, we will generate
the right query for you.
And we will do that.
You can send them as an
array, send them as a list,
doesn't really matter.
If Room can understand
it, it will do it for you.
Now the most important
part about Room
is that once we let you
define all these things,
make sure Room understands
these queries-- does not just
say, like, you know, take
this SQL and then compile it
and generate the code.
Room understands it, knows
what you are trying to do.
And this gives us
a lot of power.
For example, if Room
looks at this query,
says, OK, this is a select query
with this bind parameter, which
is passed in as a string, and
it knows it is from the feed
table, and it wants to
return items as feeds,
then Room goes and says,
OK, can I validate this?
Yeah.
The table has these
three columns.
The feed item is
these three columns.
These match.
They are fine.
You could have another class
in sort of that feed that
has these three fields.
Room will still work
Now after this verification,
let's say you made a typo.
The reason why we define
all those constants
or use Java builders,
is it would be typing,
like mistyping queries.
Room can do this validation
for you, similar to Java code,
right?
You don't use
builders to write Java
code You write your Java code.
Compilers tells
you if it is wrong.
And the ID helps you with this.
So the reason why we
don't have builders
is that we think helping
you write SQL query
is the job of Android Studio,
which they are working on it.
But once you write
the query, Room
verifies that it is correct.
So if you do this
mistake, Room will not
let you compile the application.
Similarly, if you
access some columns that
doesn't exist in the
database, again, it
will be a compile time error.
By the way, it can be any query.
You might be
joining five tables.
Room will still understand.
You may have grouping, like
almost anything in SQL.
Let's say we made that mistake
like that where we only
fetch the subtitle column.
But you want to
return this as a feed.
Now, in this case,
the feed object
also has a subtitle column.
So this might be intentional.
Maybe you are going to fill
in those fields later on
or you made a mistake.
We don't know.
In this case, Room just
generates a warning.
It says, hey, feed classes
these two other fields
that you are not
returning from the query.
It will just give
you all the details--
well, what the query returns.
Maybe you made a typo.
And what are the
fields in the column--
in the entity?
Now, there are two ways you
can get rid of this warning.
The first thing you
can do is, maybe
you really want to return
them as feed instances.
And I can tell the
Room to ignore it.
I know what I am doing.
Suppress this warning.
Alternatively, you can just
create any class, as I said.
You can just say, return
me these as a string.
You are returning one
column as a string.
And Room will do it for you.
Very similarly, what if you
are returning ID and title?
In that case, again,
Room will say, well,
there's two columns, one string.
That doesn't match.
It will give you an error.
When that happens, we
can just create a POJO.
Again, any class in
your application,
as long as we can
read what's inside it
and it matches what
the query returns,
we will generate the code.
And to make the match, you can
rename the columns in SQLite.
All of those things works here.
Now, this Room does
everything automatically.
But sometimes, you have
classes we don't know about.
Now I want Kirill
to talk about them.
How do we extend Room, Kirill?
KIRILL GROUCHNIKOV: Thank you.
So let's talk about something
a little bit more interesting.
Going back to this feed
object that has one ID integer
field and two strings,
these are primitive types
that are directly supported by
the underlying SQLite database.
What happens if you want to
add a field of a type that
is not directly supported by
SQLite, such as Java util date?
In this case, at
compile time, Room
is going to tell us,
well, I can't really
figure out how to save this.
You need to help me out.
And the way you help
out, in this case,
is provide two methods to
take your original data,
convert it to something
that SQLite can store,
so that is going
into the database.
And on the way out, when
you're doing the queries,
convert back from that
representation in the database
to your original data type.
You implement these two methods.
In this particular case, we
are converting date to long,
and back from long to date.
We annotate them.
As Yigit said, we
love annotations.
We use the type
converter annotations
on these two methods.
And then we take these
MyConverters class
and use the type converters
annotation pointing
to these two methods-- pointing,
essentially, to this class that
has our conversion methods.
You can put it directly on the
field in your entity object.
You can put it on the
entity object itself.
You can put it onto your
data access object class
or the specific query in it.
Or you can put it on
your database class.
No matter where you put it, at
compile time and at runtime,
Room will do the right thing
to find those two methods.
Now with this, we
can write a query
that finds the list
of all the feeds
that were posted between two
specific dates, "from" and
"to".
So here, since we are
accessing the "from"
and "to" fields, or columns
in the database, that
are defined as long, when the
database table is created,
you don't really
want to use "long"
as the implementation detail.
Since you are using the date
class for your entity data
field, you want to use the date
objects in the query itself.
And this is what you do here.
And when the query runs,
these two values, from and to,
are going to be
converted to longs.
The query will run.
And on the way back, when
Room constructs and fields
these feed objects, it's going
to convert back from long
to dates.
Now, let's talk about even
more complicated stuff.
What happens if you
have a class hierarchy
in your kind of data
model universe that has
object graph that is not flat?
In this case, we are adding a
location object that has two
double fields--
latitude, longitude--
into our feed.
Now, what happens
at compile time?
Once again, at
compile time, you need
to tell Room how to store this
field since, especially here,
it's not a primitive
type, but it's a type that
has subfields in it.
So one option is going
back to our type adapters.
You can do something like,
take latitude and longitude
and convert them into a
single, concatenated string
with some kind of,
let's say, semi-colon
as a separator on the way in.
And on the way back, it is
going to be some kind of a split
where the string goes back
through these two doubles.
Or you can go to do
something like bit masking
and bit shifting to try and
convert these two doubles
and code them in one long field.
This is going to
be hard to query,
even for this simple case,
when we only have two
doubles that we are
trying to encode.
We're trying to compact
it into one field.
And the more complicated
the data structure is,
the harder it becomes to use
type adapters for these cases.
Another option is
to say that I'm
going to flatten everything--
that you are going to
flatten everything for us.
So instead of having
the location data
field in your data entity,
you are essentially
flattening all the fields
from the location class
into the main feed class.
And then, Room is going to
create these two latitude,
longitude columns, which works.
But first of all, you
lose the encapsulation.
Now you just look at the
definition of your data class,
of this feed object--
or somebody else in your
project looks at that--
and it's not really clear
that these two objects
represent one single entity.
And another thing
is just because you
want to persist this object
and later on retrieve it,
why should you be changing
the definition of your data
classes?
That's not good.
Instead, there's another
option, which is also not ideal.
You can say we have
two data classes.
Why don't we store
these objects,
each one in its own
separate database table?
So we have our feed
object with ID title,
subtitle, and
posted at, the date.
And then we have the
location-- latitude, longitude.
Now, in order to connect
them, not when you say,
but when you retrieve
them, in order
to connect the location
back to its feed,
you need to have
the primary key,
the feed ID so that they
are combined together.
Once again, it works.
First of all, yet another
table is not very clean.
But also, going back to
what I mentioned before,
why should you be forced
to change and tweak
the definition of your
data model classes
just because you
want to persist them?
So what would be
ideal is that you
have your clean
separation of how
you define your data classes.
But at runtime, the way the
feed object is persisted
is in one flattened table.
So essentially, the latitude
and longitude fields
from the location are
flattened into the same table.
And the way you do it is with
this embedded annotation.
At compile time and
at runtime, Room
is going to figure out how to
flatten your entire hierarchy
into this one table.
Now you can write a query
like this in your data access
object.
We are going to
select all the feeds
in the specific geographical
rectangular area.
As you can see,
we are referencing
latitude and longitude
in the query directly.
They're not in a separate table.
And you are just using the same
names for the database columns
as the attributes in
your location object.
You can write a query
like this to select
the location for the specific
feed based on the feed ID.
And Room is going to figure
out that, while it needs
to fetch the entire
row from the database,
it only needs to create and
fill the location object,
because this is what this
method wants to return.
Or if you want to be more
specific, you can say,
I only want you to fetch
the latitude and longitude
from that table.
The last part about
embedded objects
is what happens when you
have more than one field
of the same kind
of nested class.
So in this case, we want
to store two locations.
So what is going to
happen at compile time,
Room is going to say,
as I was flattening
these fields into one
database table definition,
I see that the
same latitude field
is defined by two objects.
And since SQLite doesn't
support having two columns
with the same name in
the same database table,
it's going to fail as an
error, not as a warning.
And what you need
to do, is in case
you do want to have
something like this, to have,
in this particular
case, two locations,
you want to use the
prefix attribute
on the embedded annotation.
At compile time and
at runtime, it's
going to be used as Room is
flattening the data graph
definition.
It's going to use this
prefix to create latitude,
longitude for the original,
for the first location,
and seen latitude,
seen longitude
for the second location object.
Now, let's talk
about observability.
For those of you
who have listened
to yesterday's
introduction session
and who have been here
earlier in the day
to listen to the life
cycle live data view model,
we want to talk
about observability.
So this is a simple query
that returns a list of feeds
based on a particular query.
This is kind of a
snapshot, a point in time
where you have run this query.
And however many
feeds it returns,
it represents the state
of your data universe
at that particular moment.
What happens if your
data is dynamic?
It can be manipulated directly
by your users in the app.
Or maybe it's pushed or
pulled down from the server.
So in this case,
if one of the feed
changes in the
database, when you
add new feeds, when you delete
existing feeds that match
this query, every single time
to reflect these changes back
onto the screen, you would
need to refresh this query
explicitly, to run this
query again and again.
Instead of returning
list of feeds,
you can wrap this
return object--
it can be a single feed
or a list of feeds--
in a live data object.
This instructs Room not only
to fetch it once, but also
update the LiveData--
the callback that you pass
to the LiveData when you call
the .observe-- we'll
see it in a few slides--
every single time any
one of the objects that
were returned by this
query was changed,
or new objects were added, or
existing objects were removed
from the result of the query.
And this is my favorite part by
far of architecture components.
And also, we provide
support for using Flowable
from our RxJava 2.
So let's say-- like this one.
OK, so let's see an example
of how Room integrates
with the rest of lifecycle
aware and lifecycle aware parts
of architecture components.
We're going to start with a
simple database interface.
It has one method
to load the data
for a specific user, and
one method to save the data.
The first time, it is going
to be a simple insert.
And then as the data changes,
it's going to be an update
or replace.
As you can see here, instead
of rejoining the user
object directly in
our load method,
we're returning a live data
that traps the information
about this user.
Now, we're going to set up the
data binding to actually show
the information on that user,
perhaps in the Details page
or somewhere in some
kind of a profile page.
We have our lifecycle activity.
It can be a lifecycle fragment.
It can be a lifecycle service,
or your custom lifecycle owner.
In this case, we're
using lifecycle activity.
And in on create, we're going
to get access to our database
and database access object.
We're going to call
our load method that
returns the live data
that traps that user data.
And now, we are going to
use the observe method
on this live data object
passing two parameters.
The first parameter
is the reference
to the lifecycle owner.
This is our activity.
And the second parameter
is the callback
that is going to be
invoked by Room at runtime
every time this user information
changes in the database
on the first load or on
the subsequent updates.
Now a word of caution.
Because it's kind
of like, you know,
we don't want to put
too many lines of code
here on one slide,
you usually don't
want to expose database details
or details about loading
this information
from your web service
or caching it locally in some
form directly to the activity
or directly to the fragment.
So this code is
highly recommended
to be put in a view model.
And once again, the
most powerful part
here is the connection between
the lifecycle activity,
the owner, that says I'm
active, I am not active,
and the live data
that Room returns
as a result of this
particular query.
The callback that you provide
as the second parameter
to the method, once
again, it's going
to be invoked every
time Room detects
that the result of that
query that you wrote,
select star from the user
database table, has changed.
Once again, the
flow of information
is one part of your app.
It can be some kind of a
service that pulls information
from your back end.
Or maybe the information
is pushed through some kind
of network tickles.
It gets updates on the data.
It's using this save method
to insert the information
into the database or update
the existing information.
As the data is updated
in the database,
Room is going to
detect at runtime,
all those active
places in your app--
activity fragment
service, or your custom
lifecycle owners
that are active,
and that are subscribed or
are observing a live data
object that traps
the information
that has been updated.
And then this callback
is going to be invoked,
letting you know that
most probably you
want to update
whatever slice of data
is right now showing in
the application screen.
So for example, it
can be an app that
shows live results
for some sports games,
or live updates for the weather,
wherever you happen to be,
or live updates to
market stock prices.
One part of your app
handles the data flow.
Get that information and display
and insert it into the database
or update in the database.
And the other part gets notified
by Room and the live data
that the information
now has new data.
And you need to update
whatever the presentation is,
once again, in your
activity, in your fragment
or in your service that
posts maybe notification
that handles a widget.
YIGIT BOYAR: All right.
Thank you.
So let's focus on another
important topic, which
is relations.
Now SQLite is a
relational database.
So it can understand the
relations between entities.
And if you are using any ORM on
Android or any other platform,
they usually try to handle
these relations for you.
So let's look at it,
how it works in Room.
So if we have a
feed, we probably
also has a user object, which
has posted this feed active.
So you want to have a user
field inside that field,
inside that entity.
If you do this in
Room, it actually
wants compiled application.
The moral of the story--
we don't allow entities
to contain other entities.
Now you're probably asking, why?
Everybody else does this.
And if we can understand all
this SQLite, why can't we just
enable this?
Well, there's a very particular
reason for us not to do this.
Is we have seen
a lot of problems
with applications caused
by these kind of models.
So I just want to go
through an example.
So first, let's
look at this query.
Starts to select a
feed with some ID.
When we select this feed or
you look at this feed item,
you cannot know whether it
also fetches the user or not.
It's very hard to define.
And most of the ORMs, the way
they solve this problem is,
you just say, lazy loading.
Until the user wants
to fetch that data,
don't load it, which
works very well if you're
working on the server side.
But on the UI, it is a
little bit more tricky.
So it's implied
that lazy loading.
We could just generate
this code for you.
You could say, just
keep a user ID,
or say keep a user instance.
When we get, user is
called we can say,
if the user is the first time,
now fetch it from the database.
Otherwise, just return
the existing [INAUDIBLE].
It's very easy.
We believe this is actually a
mine planted in your code base.
Let's see how we explode it.
We are using a recycler view
where we show these feed items.
And I will get
the feed and we'll
show the title and the
subtitle of the feed item.
So it looks fine.
And then like two months later,
your product manager comes.
Actually, you know what?
Let's show the user name
in that feed item, as well.
It make sense.
It's like, OK.
So easy.
Your developer goes, just adds
feed, get user, get user name,
puts it on text view.
You are done.
You send the code to review.
It looks obvious.
It passes the code review.
You test it.
It looks fine, as well.
But when your users
start using it,
and then your application
starts receiving these ANRs,
which stands for
"Application" Not Responding."
This happens because when you
are testing the application,
your own device.
There is good network.
Everything is fast.
But when the user is
using their application,
there's probably like
50 other applications
that they're also trying to run.
And if you want
to relate to this,
just try to use your
application when Play Store is
updating your applications.
You will see how it feels.
I mean, these are
still mobile devices.
The disk on these devices is
actually relatively slower.
And the UI thread only
has 60 milliseconds.
So even if your query
takes five milliseconds,
like ignore all the
locks and everything.
Uses five milliseconds.
Five milliseconds
is a lot of time.
You can probably like lay out
20 recycler views at that time.
So how do you solve
this problem with Room?
Now previously, we said SQLite
is in a relational database.
We should just take
advantage of it.
We just keep the user ID.
We know the feed is a user ID.
Just keep it.
And now, we can
write a query that
says I want title,
subtitle, and username.
And join me these two
tables on this constraint.
Like this is already a solved
problem on the SQLite lang.
Why don't we just embrace it?
When you do this, it's faster.
You only fetch
the data you need.
And when you fetch the data,
you know that data is in memory.
And I'll say, wait.
What is this item?
It can be like any Java class.
It may even have a constructor
with public fields,
public final fields.
Room will set this
with [INAUDIBLE].
We will use that constructor.
You can even say,
return live data.
Because Room knows
about the query,
it knows it's querying
these two tables.
Think about the other example.
If you were observing the
feed, if the user changes,
how do we know it should
validate the feed or not?
But when you wrote
this, we actually know.
We know what you are returning.
We know which tables
you're querying.
So we can be clever about this.
So it's what we tell people.
If you want to have relations
and you cannot use embedded
or type adaptors, you
probably want to use POJOs
for your relations, which
means you don't have any hidden
costs.
You only fetch what you need.
And it's still observable.
And you don't need to
do anything for that.
But of course, we said
SQLite is relational
and supports foreign keys.
Room supports foreign
keys, as well.
So inside your
entity, you can say,
this entity has a foreign
key to this other entity,
where I want to match the
ID column in that entity
with this child column.
SQLite foreign keys
also support like, you
may have multiple fields
matching multiple fields
in the other tables.
It's very complex.
You should just
go ahead and read.
But once you declare
this, now SQLite
knows about this relationship.
And if it knows, you can say
things like, you know what?
If someone tries to
delete that user,
don't let them delete, because
I have a feed for them.
Or you can say, if that user
is updated, please update me,
as well.
So we're trying to embrace
SQLite rather than trying
to hide these details and
create a bunch of pitfalls.
Index is another great thing.
Now the SQLite keeps the data
on the disk in a structured way
so that you can query it back.
If we're going to
query like this
where you want to
select feed items,
which has a certain title.
But if you just write this query
and don't do anything else,
that means SQLite needs to
go through every single row
in the database to find
the ones that are matching.
Now, if you're not making this
query frequently, that's fine.
But if this is the query
that you run frequently,
you probably want to index it.
It's very simple in Room.
You just, inside the
entity annotation,
you can say, well, can you
please index this column?
If your query is
like this where your
have like, you query title
and subtitle together,
you can also create
a composite index,
which means these two things
will be indexed together.
So if you are querying
together, that will be fast.
And you can have
multiple indexes.
It doesn't matter.
By the way, just because
you're querying something,
doesn't mean you should index
it, because every index you add
has a cost on every
insertion or data change.
So you need to just measure and
see, well, what's the best way?
And SQLite's documentation
on query planner is amazing.
If you read that, you will
know how to write queries
and how to optimize it.
Now testing-- we
know in the past
we haven't been very
good in this area.
But when we were designing
architecture components,
testing was a very, very
important topic for us.
We want to have whatever
we create for architecture
components, that they can
scale, and that can be testable.
So let's look at how you
can test your queries.
By the way, you
should really test.
Just because we are
verifying your SQL queries
doesn't mean that that's
what you really intended.
Your Java code compiles.
But you still test it.
Similarly, if your
Room SQL compiles,
you should still test it.
But testing Room is
actually very easy.
Now, we still recommend
testing on the device.
But there's no
activity on your UI.
So they run faster.
You can also test on
the JVM by changing
the SQLite bindings we use.
So I'm just going
through a sample case.
So before each test is
created, I create my database.
But I create an
in-memory database,
which means the database will
be created when the test starts.
And I can clean it afterwards.
You want these tests to run
isolated from other tests.
So you don't want to
save the data into disk.
So I say after, just close
the database so the memory
can be released fast.
And I can write it as--
this is just like
I create an item.
I insert it to Room and then
make some queries on it.
And I verify that
is what I expect.
But the way Room is
designed actually
helps with the overall
application testing.
So you remember we talked about
those DAO classes we generate?
Because you defined how
you access the database
as an interface, which has
nothing to do with SQL,
you can very, very
easily mock it.
So if you have a view model that
you want to test, first of all,
you can test view
models on your computer.
You don't need to run
them on the device.
You can create a mock
of that DAO You can just
use Mockito to mock it.
And now you can write
a test like this,
like when loadFeed with
these parameters called,
return these feeds.
Because it's just
a Java interface,
there's not even any
mention of database there.
So it's all very well abstracted
without you doing anything.
Now, migrations is
another important topic.
So as you use the
application over time,
your entities will change.
Let's say if you have
these user objects,
now we start to
show user photos,
so you want to add this
new field into that.
If you do that when you run
the application, as soon as you
first access the
database, Room will say,
oops, looks like you
changed the schema,
but you didn't
increase the version.
It's going to crash
your application.
Now you need to handle this.
You can simply increase
your database version
in the annotation,
which means you don't
want any of the previous data.
You want to start from scratch.
Or you could write a migration.
Now, to write the migrations
in our database builder,
you can just pass a couple
of migration implementations.
Like this one says, I know how
to migrate from one to two.
You can have one from two
to three, three to four.
And then Room will
run whatever necessary
from the current version on the
device to your latest version.
It will just chain them.
And if anything in
the middle is missing,
it's going to
recreate the database.
Another important thing to
know-- in these migrations,
don't use any constants.
Always use full SQLite,
because over time,
your application will change,
those constants may change,
and you will get bugs.
OK, we wrote this.
But we said testing
is important, right?
So Room also comes with a
testing name and artifact.
We have separate
artifacts so that you
can test your migrations.
Now, just is a couple of steps.
First, when we compile Room, we
can actually ask Room to export
the schema-- that's how
your database looks--
into some JSON files, which
you should be committing
to your version control system.
Pass argument.
And then we want these schema
files to be visible to our test
so that we can access them.
Last but not least,
for our Android test,
we add this new
dependency from Room
which includes some helper
classes that will help us
with our migration testing.
So let's say we are trying to
test a migration from version
one to three.
Does this migration
test helper class,
which comes from that artifact?
We create an instance
of that helper.
This canonical name is how Room
exports these files by default.
We don't need to
think about it much.
And we create an
open helper factory.
One we have that, we say, OK,
migrate from one to three.
We ask helper to create
the database at version 1.
You may even have entities
that doesn't exist anymore.
It doesn't matter,
because it did
export the schema previously.
By reading that, it's going
to recreate your database
in that version.
You can just change it directly
from whatever you want.
But as you realize, this
doesn't return your DAO.
It just returns your
database instance,
because DAO may not
be valid anymore.
You can just say,
run these migrations
and validate the schema.
Well, then we give
the database name.
We give it the version we want.
Now, you may have tables
that you had before.
And maybe you want
to still keep them,
but don't tell Room about it.
So you can decide whether we
should check for these or not.
And now you give a
list of migrations.
These are all
migrations we have.
What Room will do is
migrate the database
from the previous version
to the new version,
and then check the
schema for you.
And then if you have
custom things like change
the entities in the previous
versions to the new versions,
then you can manually
assert on these things.
OK, so that was Room.
We have a very detailed
documentation on the web page.
By the way, like we do for Room,
also for all our architecture
components, we have a testing
artifact which includes
one rule for JUnit and one rule
for your instrumentation test,
that helps with dealing with
the background test we use.
So we want to make
sure everything
we have here is testable.
And if it is not,
we will fix it.
So what's next for you?
Room is available today.
Please go check it.
Play with it.
See how it looks.
Check out
developer.andorid.com/arch,
which is the main page for
all of these architecture
components.
Now we say, these can
work independently.
But these also work
very well together,
as we've seen in the live
data example Kirill had.
So check it out.
And also check out the codelabs.
We have codelabs for
both Room and lifecycles.
And they're available
in the code lab.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]